الزعيم القاسي صاحب الاستعراضات النوويه
والمعروف بشده
واسعا بصوارخه البالستيه او تصريحاته التي
تحمل التهديدات واضحه للغرب الزعيم الغامض
لطالما اخفى حياته العائليه عن عدسات
الاعلام واعيون شعب كوريا الشماليه ايضا
تكشف تلك العدسات عن الجانب الاخر في
حياته عن نساء في حياتكم
انظار العالم الى زوجه احد اكبر
الديكتاتوريات فسيده الاولى لكوريا
الشماليه ظهرت في مناسبه عده الى جانب
زوجها الاستخبارات الكوريه الجنوبيه
استطاعت ان تفيد بمعلومات عن السيده
الجميله
لترجيح زواج الثنائي في العام 2009 والذي
بقي في الظل حتى العام 2012
استطاعت ريم باناقتها وابتسامتها الدائمه
ان تطغى على القسوه المعتده في ظهوركم
وكان غيابها المتوتر مصدر جدلا يتطالها
العديد من الشائعه
كميون جونغ التي درست مع شقيقها في سويسرا
فاجات العالم بظهورها في مناصب رفيعه
بالدوله واظهرت جانبا لا يقل حده عنكم
تصريحات الناريه اطلقتها كيميا جونغ طالبت
فيها رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه ان يغلق فمه
مهدده للغربه ومتغنيه بكوريا الشماليه حتى
اصبح دورها السياسي موضع تكهنات بالتزامني
مع معلومات عن تدهور صحه كينج اون في
العام 2020
ليطرح السؤال عن امكانيه ان ترثه
منصبه شقيقها
[موسيقى]
بمعطف ابيض ممسكه بيدي والدها وقفت ابنتكم
الى جانب الصاروخ البالستي تم اطلاقه
بعدها بقليل ظهور للمره الاولى حل له
البعض على انه احتمال الانتقال الزعامه
الى جيل الرابع من عائلتكم بينما اوحى
لاخرين بانه اشاره للاستجابه الى الضغوط
الدوليه
للحد من برنامج السلاح النووي في سوريا
[موسيقى]
امام العالم او انكم
يرسم لهن هاله مشابهه اذا عمر العربيه